um all the years of uh young's work as
as it was developing he did have a
circle of people around him who were
quite closely related yes and
um did he
appreciate that did he that he had
uh loyal friends and uh did he find that
a comfort because so much of what he did
was groundbreaking oh yes he even
in one is these letters i have found
among my patients
pupils and and with son a friendship
pro-life has developed
and they carry on my work i mean he was
full
very appreciative was very glad not to
be quite alone you know
such a pioneering work one is very
isolated
so if somebody was able to follow him to
come along
he was always very happy
he seems to have found um not as many
men
who could join him or is that your
impression i don't know
oh there were some men who followed you
who
with whom you had very good contact but
naturally
there was also a lot of trouble because
you see men especially men
in this he got better on with men in
another field
poets writers artists and so on
because they don't compare themselves
with him they had the feeling i am a
good painter
i am a good writer and this is a good
psychologist
but if you are in the same field there
was always jealousy
they compared themselves with him and
then they felt crushed and inferior
and then they they became nasty
that was a very regular pattern you saw
with many
who were working in the field of
psychology and psychiatry
it needs a certain generosity to
to appreciate a great person of your
same sex
and the devil always whispers to you
he's better i'm better he's only that
i'm better in the old jealousy
and then and then they create trouble he
took great trouble
to avoid that but he
in a way he was a crushing personality
for a man
you know he did everything better he was
better in psychology but then he
painted beautifully he could cut it
stoney
so so whenever you compared yourself
with him you felt
like a louse and that naturally created
a lot of
secret poison yeah